en el vídeo anterior vimos la
sustitución núcleo física aromática con
una reacción de adición eliminación en
este vídeo veremos una reacción de
adición eliminación con la formación de
una bencina como intermediario empezamos
con bromo benceno y agregaremos unidad
de sodio que es una base fuerte y
amoniaco líquido observen que
sustituimos el halógeno por el grupo am
y no formando anilina como nuestro
producto echemos un vistazo al mecanismo
empezaremos con la parte de eliminación
eliminación nuestra amiga de sodio
funcionará como una base entonces
dibujemos el avión por aquí
la base toma este protón dejando estos
electrones en el carbón dibujemos el
resultado de esta reacción ha sido base
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo el grupo
saliente
y tenemos una carga formal negativa en
este carbono hemos formado un carbón
resaltemos algunos electrones estos
electrones formaron el carbón que se
encuentra en la posición [ __ ] respecto
al grupo saliente si estos electrones se
mueven hacia el anillo formarán un
triple enlace eso permite que estos
electrones se puedan ir junto con el
halógeno que se convierte en unión
hemos creado una molécula de bencina
estos electrones formaron un triple
enlace pero es un intermediario muy
inestable resulta que esta molécula es
muy reactiva así que el siguiente paso
es la adición
aquí tenemos nuestra molécula de bencina
la molécula de bencina reaccionará con
el año a mitad
pero esta vez en la unión funcionará
como núcleo filo y atacar a uno de los
carbonos del triple enlace digamos que
ataca de este lado lo que empujará estos
electrones de regreso a este carbono
dibujemos el resultado aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo
y ahora tenemos un nh 2 unido al anillo
y estos electrones entonces los
electrones en rosa se movieron para
formar nuevamente un karma neón en la
posición [ __ ] nuestro último paso es la
protón acción del anillo así que una
molécula de amoniaco entra y funcionará
como un ácido donar a un protón estos
electrones en rosa toman un protón
dejando estos electrones
hemos formado anilina como nuestro
producto
muy bien veamos un problema aquí tenemos
un anillo de sustituido los sustituye
entes se encuentran en posición para
respecto al otro y agregaremos a medida
de sodio que tiene una carga forma
negativa el primer paso es la
eliminación
lo primero que ocurre es una reacción ha
sido base nuestra amiga tomará un protón
que se encuentre cerca del halógeno
podría tomar este protón o esté en este
caso no importa cual ya que es una
molécula simétrica digamos que tomará
este protón dejando estos electrones en
el carbono dibujemos el resultado aquí
tenemos nuestro anillo
un grupo metilo y nuestro halógeno
ahora tenemos una carga forma negativa
en este carbono entonces estos
electrones se moverán para formar un
triple enlace empujando estos electrones
que se irán junto con el grupo saliente
el cloro se va y así formamos nuestra
bencina como intermediario esta es
nuestra bencina
recuerden que escogí este protón para la
reacción ácido base pero pudo haber sido
este entonces obtenemos nuestra bencina
y la haremos reaccionar con nuestra
amiga que ahora funcionará como núcleo
filo podría atacar por cualquier lado
del triple enlace si ataca por este lado
estos electrones se moverán hacia acá
dibujemos el resultado
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo nuestro n h
un par de electrones libres y nuestro
grupo metilo ahora si el núcleo filo
ataca de este lado del triple enlace
empujaría los electrones hacia este
carbono dibujemos lo que resultaría
nuevamente tenemos nuestro anillo
el grupo metilo ahora agregamos nuestro
nh 2 del lado derecho y aquí nos queda
el par de electrones libres finalmente
sólo necesitamos protón ar el anillo no
mostraré el mecanismo pero dibujemos los
productos en este caso nuestros grupos
nos quedan en posición para respecto al
otro
y en este nos quedan en posición meta
así que obtendremos una mezcla de
productos veamos otro tipo de reacción
de eliminación usando este mecanismo
esta vez en lugar de usar unidad de
sodio usaremos hidróxido de sodio que
también es una base fuerte calentaremos
y necesitamos agregar una fuente de
protones observen que al final un grupo
h sustituye nuestro halógeno esta es una
reacción muy famosa ahora veamos el
problema de abajo aquí tenemos un grupo
metilo y a diferencia del problema
anterior se encuentra en posición meta
respecto al cloro nuevamente pensemos en
el and johnny hidróxido funcionando como
base tomará un protón del anillo
recuerde debe ser un protón que se
encuentre junto al grupo saliente así
que podría tomar este protón
o este pero ahora son dos posiciones
diferentes
así que obtendremos dos intermediarios
pensemos primero en el protón de la
derecha si este protón se va estos
electrones se moverán para formar el
triple enlace dibujemos el resultado
con la eliminación del halógeno nos
queda una bencina
este es un posible intermediario pero si
tomamos este protón el halógeno sale y
nos queda otra bencina
esta vez el triple enlace se formará
entre este hidrógeno y el cloro justo
aquí observen que los enlaces pi dentro
del anillo están dibujados diferente
pero no hay problema ahora que ya
tenemos nuestros dos posibles
intermediarios en el siguiente paso
nuestro hidróxido funcionará como núcleo
filo para este caso pensemos en que el
núcleo filo ataca de este lado del
triple enlace dibujemos el producto
final
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo del grupo
metilo y nuestro h en posición para
respecto al grupo metilo este es un
posible producto usaré otro color para
que se vea mejor entonces este ataque
núcleo físico nos daría este producto
pero si tuviéramos este ataque núcleo
físico obtendríamos un producto
diferente aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
el grupo metilo y ahora hemos agregado
el h a este carbono entonces hemos
obtenido dos productos diferentes y
podemos hacer lo mismo con esta molécula
dibujemos el producto si el hidróxido
ataca del lado izquierdo del triple
enlace
y así quedaría uno de los productos pero
hay otro posible producto podríamos
atacar por el lado derecho del triple
enlace así que para nuestra cuarta
posibilidad aquí tenemos el anillo
nuestro grupo h y nuestro grupo metilo
si se dan cuenta estos dos productos son
la misma molécula los electrones py
están dibujados diferente pero sabemos
que solo son estructuras de resonancia
así que en total obtuvimos tres
productos esta sería una molécula
y 3
en un examen no tienen mucho tiempo para
dibujar todo el mecanismo pero piensen
en la eliminación del halógeno para
formar su bencina como intermediario
piensen en cuántos intermediarios son
posibles y finalmente piensen en agregar
el núcleo filo en alguno de los lados
del triple enlace eso les dará los
posibles productos para su respuesta